hello there reject nation
I'm Greg Allen I'm John Humphrey we're
gonna watch a video that just came out
four years ago
final fantasy zip the flames of truth
zip I believe that is a translation for
Wales Virginia okay so one of our top of
war tears at our patreon if you are a
follower of our channel you would know
that we sometimes do this is whatever
video you request we must definitely
cover and put up on the youtubes whether
that is a reaction or a topic discussion
and today is a reaction for this game
trailer cinematic treasures and we like
checking these out now John and I get
ready to click off the video do not play
the Final Fantasy games I play the movie
this comes from a man named Christopher
Kenny and I did ask him is there any
context we need to know before we watch
this he gave an answer that kind of just
confused me a little bit more so let's
just hop into this his answer was
basically unfortunately all the videos I
give you backstory assume that you know
about the events of the video so the
spoil it for you which would be
counterintuitive and he was basically
talking about how they redeveloped this
game to make it so much better than the
one that came before it apparently very
buggy so now I'm like all right that
doesn't really tell me much let's see if
we can latch on to any of this
experience and I'm expecting some Alec
Baldwin's and Ving Rhames let's get it
on
there's a one alcohol room
we're back a Catholic Mass little
gregorian change
this reminds me of the Godzilla truth
yeah so I was thinking
whoa Wow as a not a positive situation
right now hey man they could come in
peace if they're sentient gorgeous
environments like that's my favorite
kind of battle shop Hey oh yeah yeah
lines collides
oh my goodness oh he's my favorite
character
[Music]
[Music]
you could have guns huh yeah it looks
like thicker version
Jonte whoa
well
[Music]
whoof the Death Star
whoa
[Music]
that whole thing at Dragon ah that's the
impression I got like the entire thing
was it just it's like dragon cocoon
[Music]
Oh smell Oh light painting
[Music]
Ben Whishaw you guys are gonna lose no
no man they could pull this one out whoa
you got this not handle
[Music]
feels like what the new Hellboy movie
should look like
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
it's like a metaphysical representation
[Music]
[Music]
no I don't want to go I want to stay
right here
snapping well I think they were being
transported away from the battlefield
right
it's unfortunate you'd be a very
good-looking guy who didn't have those
ears you can get plastic surgery in the
new game
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
Oh
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
I'm like I don't know what's going on
and I am terrified in and gross with
hard ass nipple children okay force
ghost
Wow Wow like Aquaman
yeah it's not our video game you know
let's see better graphic that's them
that's some damn good visual
storytelling yeah for stay in the game
now well I I feel like obviously there's
so much we don't grasp onto but I feel
like you can keep up with the heart of
the tale okay within this story there's
good versus evil going on and then you
got Grand Master wizard badass looking
Gandalf [ __ ] it was like get out
of here I'm gonna handle this dragon and
sacrifice myself to save your asses
right now and I also love that concept
too of it seem like a period piece look
at modern day it's like a period of
realm or something like that yeah yeah
yeah and I love those concepts of when
there's like that one dragon the
harbinger total destruction yeah in just
the most ominously horrifying way with
this giant orb thing that gives birth to
a I've seen a couple of other cinematic
trailers for other Final Fantasy games
before were again I'm left going I don't
fully know the intricate details the
deeper understanding to a lot of what's
going on terms of who these characters
are but I'm always wildly impressed I'm
like this is the first reaction video
we've done for one that's something very
fascinating about you know it's like
obviously there's this whole backstory
here that we're not latched on to but we
can feel the backstory and then somehow
I'm still like emotionally captivated by
what's going on in this journey because
you find yourself like it's pretty
obviously the good guys are here oh yeah
Universal struggle that comes to that
but more even so there's just an
intensity it's like the one thing I've
learned from anime and video games both
is that those mediums are great at
communicating just like the most
harrowing cathartic intensity because
once it reaches that crescendo at the
end where it's just the old dude going
up against the dragon there's trading
these devastating blows back and forth
it is just like
soand yeah I mean for my interpretation
of what was going on is that hell was
literally rising and taking over
yeah hell's break-in loose and then our
main old guy here had to kind of get in
touch with the light and he used the
light to conquer evil and I love any
message or something like that
personally and I don't know exactly if
that's what's going on but that's what I
read to me as right yeah yeah that's how
it feels for sure you know like a noble
story of sacrifice and yeah these are
our heroes on the battlefield who kind
of make the crucial moves then that is
at him like whisking them away so he can
do this final it's very selfless - it's
a sacrifice and it might be like Generic
to always point out especially do these
reaction videos of like the graphics but
goddamn it could sense - I mean the like
we've seen things like this before these
kind of designs and whatnot but the
intricate details - every moment it's
like we've all seen a lot of what this
is even you know commenting on I love
that battle shot with the line with the
camera pulling back you've seen a lot of
movies and shows I love those kind of
cinematic angles but just to like the
details of whatever those explosion was
going on and the dragon itself was
terrifying it we're watching this like a
bunch of bright lights on
oh yeah the image is totally hellish and
like totally unsettling and the sound
design - like I was not watching this
with headphones I don't think I'd be
anywhere near as engrossed because the
sound design of everything a lot kind of
a terrifying element and the beautiful
music to go over all of it as well was
just so powerful I gotta say I'm always
impressed when we watch these kinds of
cinematic game trailers or at least the
ones we've been sent so far because they
really do just have this knack for
visual storytelling yes prowess and like
really potent imagery and stuff like
that so yeah like at least of all the
ones we've watched so far they always
draw you in and you start to think these
people could be making movies because
they're just as effective as any crazy
epic battle sequence you've seen in a
dozen movies well it's a 2015 movie and
there were images I saw in the Hellboy
trailer that made me go this kind of
looks like what the new Hellboy movie
should ultimately look like and
I was flashing to the finality of
Aquaman yeah and then also Godzilla king
of the monsters I'm like there are
elements here from a game from 2015 that
I'm seeing in modern day stuff now I
feel like anime imagery is devlin
influence in Hollywood medium today is
especially video games though it was
like this for example must play they
must oh yeah yeah as much as video game
movie has been a hard thing to crack I
think that Hollywood say yeah absolutely
and in that way video game movies have
existed for a long time man yeah a lot
of times the best video game movies are
not based off of video yes isn't that
interesting well Christopher Kenny thank
you so much for requesting this video
man would not have checked it off a worm
for you and Christopher is a guy who's
actually from South Australia Australia
yeah John's favorite accent oh few art
can actually kana do Christopher's all
the way from down under and it's pretty
crazy whenever I hear of anyone from
another country who watches our channel
it blows my mind so Christopher thank
you for being here for so long and this
homeboy over here has a big passion for
video games as well and you know we were
talking about a a word thing about doing
Let's Plays or anything like that and he
ponders with the idea of actually doing
a video game development in some
capacity but dude it's your birthday
you're gonna turn 24 on the 24th of this
month so I want to Satan in advance
happy early birthday to you buddy really
appreciate you showing your support and
maybe one day I'll be able to go down
under on you yeah and now I'm gonna sing
you a oh well you know that's much more
in fashion nowadays I feel like you're
fitting right and you're just keeping up
with the time I don't like that you
don't like that well becomes too popular
Christopher I can't promise him no more
women
you know it's women playing I'm pooping
I like it
I was going to sing Chrissa oil tea free
birthday song now no need no yeah we've
done it we already got we really got it
all right guys you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell which Final Fantasy games should we
start with I have video game systems now
help me catch up